welcome everybody something to cabinet
moving straight onto the agenda
can I have apologies for absence please
yes apologies received from councillor
Jefferson counts the Harris and from
counts like at all although he may just
be late
thank you I also understand perhaps
council Pemberton is trying to get here
but I'm not quite sure on that
particular point but he is aiming to be
here I think right the disclosure of
interest members I think we all know
about that so if there are they'll have
it now we can race now or alternatively
at an appropriate time in the in the
meeting right moving on to item three
organizational development strategy over
to Council organ and thank you chairman
the council has a staff strategy but
it's not been reviewed since 2013 the
recent pH allenge suggested that any
review should look at the development
needs of existing staff as well as
assessing skills knowledge and capacity
gaps for the future in addition to
taking this into account it has been
developed using slake stakeholder panels
and best practice and the resulting
strategy which is attached at appendix
one on page five sets out what is
required of staff and counselors in
terms of leadership behavior and
engagement to deliver the council's
vision and ambition in addition it
identifies specific actions which need
to be prioritized in order to effect
change the intention is to review this
plan annually and the recommendation is
option one in power to one which is on
page two and that is to formally adopt
the organization organizational
development strategy and recommend that
this is adopted by council thank you
Thank You councillor I must admit it I
thought it's very good report very in I
think the right word infusing I really
think it's got a very good report and
one I'm sure we can all work behind get
behind
for developments of this council into
the future so real looking forward to
that
I'll bet any other speakers on this well
in that case then I'm going to go to the
vote on this one options available to
the counter option one to formally adopt
the draft organizational development
strategy all those in favor agree thank
you moving on to the next item item for
CCTV request for additional capital
funding and I'm going to pass over to
Phil Griffin Thank You chairman the
importance of CCTV to the residents of
the district has been shown to be very
high on a number of different surveys
that have been conducted over recent
years and the refurbishment of the CCTV
system is becoming overdue now due to
the equipment becoming outdated you
recognize this last year in your budget
when you agreed to finance the partial
upgrade of the system for a sum of four
hundred and sixty-five thousand pounds
that was just partial upgrade because
even then the total costs were going to
be in the region of eight hundred
thousand pounds on the back of the
council decision last year a firm called
ADT Tyco have been engaged through a
framework agreement and since then the
project has been scoped out in more
detail with the assistance of a
technical advisor during the process
town and parish councils and others were
consulted over the existing equipment
and location of the cameras and if you
look to paragraph 1 point 7
- you will see there a list of items
which are the subject of recommendations
in the report the total extra amount of
money estimated to be required is just
over three hundred and thirty one
thousand pounds during the course of the
scoping of the project it became
apparent that there were two two
alternative options for upgrading the
system one was a wireless system and one
was a bt fiber system for reasons
outlined in the report the favored
option is for a bt fiber system the
recommendations in the report are that
you approve the total budget for the
project which is now seven hundred and
ninety six thousand pounds with ongoing
costs revenue costs of eighty four
thousand pounds and as far as the extra
three hundred thirty one thousand pounds
is concerned at recommendation two that
you agree to via a hundred and seventy
five thousand pounds from the ICT budget
revenue budget - the CCTV budget and
that you recommend to council that the
remaining amount which is one hundred
and fifty six thousand pounds be
transferred to the CCT budget from
capital reserves [ __ ] assist with any
other matters I'll be happy to help
thank you thank you I think a CCTV
service that the council does is one of
the most important elements of this
council's work and I have no hesitation
in proposing the recommendations that
are on page 22 23 even the two four
cabinet and the one to council regarding
this matter thank you thank you
councilman thank you I have no problem
with the report at all but my
understanding is that even road is the
only main road into Stratford at the
moment that doesn't have scene
see TV coverage could I request that we
look to include evesham Road in the
future coverage especially in view of
the potential location of the peony
pavilion in the first garden as you can
see in paragraph 1 6 2 there was some
consultation carried out I don't know
whether that ID was fed with into into
the consultation or not perhaps you can
help me with that but if it hasn't then
I'm sure that we can look at that for
you that's very helpful chairman thank
you just picking up a couple of points
obviously we're looking for best value
and the BT fiber option seems to hire
about revenue cost to this council but
is it a better option regards future
proofing for the future when technology
again evolves so future proofing for
technology is always a little bit of
dark art because you never can predict
what technology might come along to
replace the existing technology but all
I can say that as far as we are able to
foresee at this time that is the
recommended option partly because of it
being more likely to be future proofed
careful words there yeah I can't blame
you actually with these sort of things
it's very difficult to predict isn't it
ok any other comments
well I have a proposal for this which is
to accept the additional costs as
outlined in the report all those in
favor agreed thank you
I'd like to now move on to the next item
which is wireless broadband update
report and on that particular point and
I have ok Council house package M this
is but a brief summary of the progress
that we've made on the wireless
broadband project many of you read met
might remember that this be the UK
project to get broadband rolled out
across the whole of the country started
in 2012 it's now in contract three-stage
which runs until September 2019 there
are still 11 point four percent of the
district that is not covered
and we're told by BT UK that that is
3000 properties in the hard-to-reach
areas however thanks to OSC and in
particular to cancel the kettle we
discovered we couldn't always rely on
the BDU data and that's just being kind
so Stratford district council in
discussion with members and officers
decided to assist residents to take
advantage of the gigabyte voucher scheme
which gave them money to support their
application for broadband as a result of
that Stratford District Council
appointed a consultant the guy called
Simon Davis to research the market for
suppliers offering their services to
fill in the gaps if you like through the
broadband Strava District Council did
not want to take the risk
recommending one particular supplier so
it was decided to our Simon Davis to
research all of those companies who were
offering this service and in your blue
papers at the back of the report you'll
see that he researched 129 different
companies as a result of that an open
day was set in motion on the 20th of
September and he attracted 23 of the
approved
and over 150 residents it was deemed
very successful and that really as a
result of that other local authorities
have taken a similar approach and have
just copied the good work that was done
by David Platts and his department we
know that there is no one-size-fits-all
solution and to reach all of our
hard-to-reach residents it's going to be
difficult but we think with this
approach and the companies that have
been chosen then we stand a chance of
doing it to achieve it we need to submit
the funding bid to the local full fiber
Challenge Fund so in terms of next steps
it is proposed that we contact all
parish councils by December 2019 we
submit an expression of interest based
on feedback from the parishes in January
2019
Stage three undertake investigation into
which solution might be preferable for
each area and that during January to
March 2019 next to agreed delivery
timetable with members in specific areas
or met the existing BDU program and work
independently and that work to be
completed by March 2019 and for the bid
to be submitted then so that is the next
steps and I'll hand back to you mr.
chairman for the recommendations which
are shown under item five page 31 of
your report thank you any other comments
on this I'm just glad to say that I did
go to the meeting
the seminar and it was really very well
attended I believe and they were quite a
good selection of options available to
us or to the residents in their
far-flung reaches so I thought it's very
positive and positive meeting all right
thank you
any other comments all of them oh sweet
Casablanca
I just asked whether we know anything
about how well the 23 companies have
come back to people who've registered
with them Thank You counsel
my trusty officer to give you a visual
blind well on your blue papers you have
a pricey of each of the individual
companies but this is just a prove that
it did get done I guess this was the
this is the actual total amount of the
work that we did around those companies
so we've got their performance targets
we've got whether they've worked with
other councils what the success rate
wasn't that kind of thing so they are we
have done all that work as part of it
but have we actually had any feedback
about our event and what happened from
from those of us who attended so for
instance my business has not received
anything from the company I signed up
with and I just wonder whether we've got
any way of measuring it you know I mean
I'm in a different different position I
can go back to them but if they're not
getting back to people then that's not
going to be very helpful I think where
we're coming from is that as councilor
house said we are going to contact all
the parish councils before Christmas and
talk to them and last emperor only
anecdotal information they've got in
terms of the Giga bit of artistic aim
itself because it's run through the
government via BD UK we only get
snippets of information back from PD UK
so nothing directly to us
thank you I'm sure I didn't answer your
question but I know it's interesting it
is interesting the ride I did ask her a
little bit more information from a
couple of them only got one so yeah okay
right members the the options before us
are to accept the the newer valence
receipt to support the proposal to bid
for for external funding on behalf both
SDC and the parish councils engage with
all parish councils to case support to
be included in the bids or propose
another solution do I have a proposal
for the support the proposal for
external funding thank you
remembers that before use to support the
proposal to bid for external funding on
behalf of both SDC and project councils
engage with all parish councils to gain
support to be including other bids all
those in favor great thank you right um
gosh no other business there's no need
to exclude the public therefore I'll
close the meeting thank you